the human cost of russia's war on
ukraine hundreds of thousands of
refugees stream into poland hungary
slovakia and other countries
can they handle the influx and will the
crisis change the way the eu deals with
migration
this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad zhum beyond the tanks missiles
and political wrangling over russia's
invasion of ukraine it's the people who
are paying the price the war has created
a major humanitarian crisis in eastern
europe the un's refugee agency believes
at least 368 000 people have escaped
ukraine to neighboring countries
many have crossed into poland with
thousands more arriving in hungary
romania slovakia and moldova the unhcr
is preparing for up to four million
refugees if the conflict drags on
most of the new arrivals are women and
children as ukrainian men up to 60 years
old have been told to return and join
the fight
volunteers and ngos are doing what they
can to help as zane basravi reports from
a train station in eastern poland
beyond the reaches of the russian army
refugees from ukraine arrive in the
safety of poland
forced to take only what is most
important only what they can carry
here friendly faces open arms
and as much comfort as can be had
sheltering in a train station
vladimir shamanski was working in the
netherlands when the war broke out he's
waiting for his five sons to arrive from
across the border to take them to safety
he'll then return to ukraine where he
says he will join his wife a soldier in
the national army
ukrainians are prepared to die he says
before ever surrendering their country
to russian president vladimir putin i
can say when ukrainians lose when
ukraine loses europa is can be next one
poland and all europa in maybe
america too so help us or
or it can be the same like ukraine
ukraine's decision to conscript men of
fighting age into the armed forces has
divided families the women who have fled
with their children know that long
goodbyes may turn out to be
final farewells
but there is resilience here my
daughters
always try to have some fun
they can find fun and
somewhere
everywhere if they have some mama
toys
but older girl
feel
some they feel that
dangerous situation but we try
to be strong to not so
panic
for many of the displaced the shemeshla
train station will be the first time any
of them have seen any sort of help in
days a hot meal a place to rest
rise to cities across europe even people
opening up their own homes to offer
those displaced by the fighting in
ukraine a place to stay
there has been an outpouring of support
from volunteers who want to help any way
they can
we met maria in tears as she searched
for a mother with a newborn she had met
earlier in the day
she came back to the train station with
toys but the mother and baby are gone
i'd gladly bomb putin to england and the
us and other countries just get dozens
of planes to bomb him that's all i want
to say
there is solidarity with ukrainians and
anger at russia
as europe's latest refugees try to
figure out what to do next desperate for
news from the people they left behind
those that made it out of ukraine have a
warning for the rest of the world
millions of lives are at stake help stop
russia while you still
can zain basravi al-jazeera shemeshla
eastern poland
all right let's bring in our guests in
kharkiv in ukraine maria avdiva head of
research at the european expert
association
in geneva zhong ah gadini williams head
of global communications at united
nations high commissioner for refugees
and in paris ole solvang director of
partnerships and policy at the norwegian
refugee council a warm welcome to you
all and thanks so much for joining us
today on inside story maria let me start
with you
what's the situation like for you in
kharkiv right now and how concerned are
you about how dire the humanitarian
situation could grow in the days ahead
well for the three past days we have
been going through shellings and
yesterday they got strong
and
during the night the challenge continued
and
today in the morning we've got reports
that uh russian troops on light vehicles
have managed to enter the city in small
groups and the ukrainian military
started the operation inside the city so
on the streets fighting now we're going
and there were a lot of uh
shootings all over the place and
in the city and the explosions also the
russians during this night they exploded
the gas pipeline
in kharkiv uh we also have reports that
there are deaths among civilians and one
of the missiles got into the building
full story building with people there so
uh the situation is really threatening
people spent the night today in shelters
or in the underground which is used as a
shelter for now uh it seems that uh
so
kharkiv is under control of ukraine uh
it seems that russian forces did not
expect that they will
see such a intense fighting and
resistance from uh or ukrainian citizens
and ukrainian military so they were
pushed back uh those uh vehicles that
entered the city were destroyed so
russian forces are now
again on the previous positions near the
city but the threat is very close and
actually now the challenge starts again
and we understand that it might continue
and
get bigger
again in the night
i was spoken to the neighbors
in my place where i leave yesterday and
went to the grocery stop to see
if there is anything left
so people are really
anxious and they are really frightened
about the situation especially those
with small children and they spend the
nights in basements and in the shelters
and during the day as well going there
several times uh in the uh in the
grocery shops
there are no no no fresh products i mean
bread
milk and such kind of
of things but anyway that
people are still have
some sufficient uh supplies
so there's no crisis with that yet at
the moment and my fear is that
russia has seen that it cannot uh uh
so that ukraine doesn't is not
surrendering and the ukraine fights back
firstly they will try to use saboteurs
to blow up or
explode some infrastructure objects in
the city because we have seen a numerous
reports today from kiev that
eve military have captured the saboteurs
carrying a
explosion in their backpacks we tried to
to do it in some very important objects
inside the city
let me ask you first how is the
humanitarian response going inside
ukraine right now has unhcr and have
unhcr teams been able to access people
in need inside ukraine
well as you can imagine the situation
there is
extremely fluid extremely precarious
we've been in in ukraine for over 30
years and we've been running an
emergency operation there since 2014
but um as with everybody else in terms
of the civilian population the unhcr
staff in kiev is of course bunkered down
as well
we are still continuing where we can our
humanitarian aid deliveries so yesterday
we were able to get a truckload of
supplies out to internally displaced
people in central ukraine however many
parts of the country are completely
inaccessible so we are really calling on
access and security for humanitarian
agencies like unhcr so that we can go
out there and deliver urgently needed
life-saving assistance to anyone who is
forced to flee right now
ole from your vantage point how massive
will the humanitarian needs be
and are the humanitarian actors who are
responding to this crisis scaled up
enough right now to be able to deal with
it appropriately
i think from what it looks like at this
point i think the humanitarian needs
will be absolutely massive you know
before this recent escalation of
hostilities uh there were three million
people uh in ukraine who was in need of
assistance and i think what's also
important to remember here and kind of a
unique thing about ukraine is that so
many of those people were actually
elderly 30 were elderly and and many of
them living along the uh the the sort of
old front lines here and i think we are
together with many other humanitarian
organizations very ready to scale up and
we're now looking at how to scale up our
plans both within ukraine but also in
the neighboring countries
what we do need is commitments from our
partners from our donors to to finance
those operations
and as my colleague from unhcr just said
what we really need is is also safety
and security on the ground and and uh
that the conditions on the ground are
such that we are able to deliver that in
in in a safe way and so that that is
what we're hoping for
maria what you described to me in your
earlier answer it sounds absolutely
terrifying for those like yourself on
the ground there in harkey even in other
parts of ukraine um you were talking
about essentially the people paying the
price for all of this right now and i
want to ask you
um based on what's going on do you feel
that you your family members your loved
ones should should leave
well i myself am not going to live
anywhere because i am determined to stay
here in hakeem as much as possible
because i want to defend my home and my
city it's where i was born i don't want
to become refugee just because mr putin
uh doesn't like ukraine and wants to
have control over country that will not
happen and
now everyone counts i can help in the
way i i do i'm for example now doing and
go
given up information to the world about
what is going on so everyone knows that
the war crimes are being now
made
by russia to ukraine and uh so but but
if there will be also other help that i
could provide for example some given
some medical aid or volunteer and that i
will be ready for that as well so i i'm
staying here uh the family of the of
with elderly uh
members are
so they left kharkiv but uh uh
everyone who is now in kharkiv they are
ready to fight because that is our land
and we we don't want to
let anyone come here and say us
ukrainians what to do
when it comes to this displacement
crisis the numbers that we're already
talking about are absolutely staggering
i mean just in the last several hours
i've seen unhcr publicizing the fact
first it was 150 000 refugees from
ukraine had arrived in neighboring
countries then just a couple of hours
after that it was 300 and i believe 68
000 ukrainian refugees arriving in
neighboring countries unhcr is saying
that they are projecting that up to 4
million people could flee ukraine
can countries like poland hungary
slovakia and others can they actually
handle this influx
i think right now what we're seeing is
across the board tremendous hospitality
solidarity and and a welcome for any
ukrainians that are forced to flee and
that's throughout the entire region
and i'm not just talking about the
governments um people are literally
opening their homes collecting uh
supplies for infants for for mothers for
elderly people so i think we are seeing
a tremendous outpouring of support
however as you mentioned we are
estimating that up to four million could
flee that is a huge number we'll have to
see of course um in the coming days how
we reinforce we have
along with other humanitarian agencies
stockpiles both inside and outside
ukraine
but the needs are going to be staggering
and we're already seeing that we we will
have to reinforce everything that we
have on the ground
and then in terms of of um
your question about the ability to to
uphold all these needs i think what
maria just said is a key point which is
all the ukrainians that we are speaking
to that are arriving in poland moldova
romania hungary they're all stressing
that they want to stay close to home
they have loved ones inside they have
their homes they have their lives they
have pets they have everything that
they've been forced to leave behind as
soon as they think that it's possible
for them to go back they want to go back
so i don't think people generally want
to move further afield right now they
want to be able to go back to their
homes and their lives as as soon as
they're able to do so all right i just
want to step back for a moment and look
at another angle of all of this african
students trying to leave ukraine are
denouncing ukrainian and polish
authorities on social media videos
posted on twitter show large crowds of
young people of african descent stuck at
the border since the invasion began take
a look
we are not allowing any black people to
enter inside the gates
we are all here it's only ukrainians
that they're allowing in
even the walls with kids they're not
allowing them
here
for days and nobody's asking any
questions
only ukrainian woman and
he's they're allowing into this gate
all the places blocked and all are
pulled up blacks
from different communities
from different countries nobody's
talking to us
poland's response now is very different
to last year when soldiers stopped
thousands of mainly syrian afghan and
kurdish refugees crossing over from
belarus it's also in contrast to how
european nations dealt with more than
one million refugees who entered during
the 2015 migrant crisis
olay let me ask you about this um
i'm struck by the fact that the response
is so different right now i spent a lot
of time in europe in 2015 covering the
refugee crisis and one of the borders
that i spent a lot of time was the
serbian border with hungary
and i saw refugees mainly from
syria
iraq afghanistan other countries
that were forced back into serbia by
patrol men on horses
a lot of these refugees men women and
children
were beaten back they were injured when
trying to come in
to hungary
and of course there's been a lot of
controversy these past several years
about the eu's migration policy
when you see how different the response
is right now to refugees from ukraine
who obviously should be given safe
harbor but when you see how different
the response is to the refugees from
ukraine
to
what the actions were when it was
refugees coming from
syria iraq afghanistan and other
countries what do you make of that
well i think this is something that we
need to
reflect over and i think you know this
is a
it's an incredibly important principle
in international law that anybody who is
in need of safety should receive it
where they where they might be able to
get it and this has been the position of
the norwegian refugee council as well in
the last in these last several years as
we have seen people from other places
other uh around the world seeking refuge
in in europe is that we have to uh let
those with real protection need in and
to make sure that they are safe as well
um you know it is uh it is as you say uh
a um
and sort of a very conspicuous
difference here in terms of how uh how
european countries have reacted to these
different situations uh but what i hope
perhaps is that we can take with us kind
of some of the lessons or reflections
from this crisis in in ukraine and how
we have responded to that so that we
also can have more empathy from
to uh for people who are coming from
other parts of the world and that we see
i hope that we will see a more open
attitude to those people as well going
forward
jung ah the german interior minister has
said that europe should agree on
accepting ukrainian refugees without
bureaucratic hurdles
from your perspective from your point of
view do you think that this crisis may
change the way that the eu deals with
migration going forward
it's very possible i mean obviously it's
early days and and things are just
changing not only daily but hourly but i
do think that we do have precedence in
in other situations during the bosnian
conflict for example during the kosovo
conflict we did have uh situations where
um with the the conflict in europe um
different european countries did come to
agreements on on how
many refugees they would accept and also
what uh what would be the the rights and
the services that they would be allowed
so already i i think that these
discussions are taking place um we're
glad that they're taking place sooner
rather than later
but i think right now it's it's uh
humanitarian access and humanitarian aid
that is the most important need on the
ground
maria when you speak to
friends of yours colleagues in ukraine
who have made that extremely difficult
and traumatic decision to leave
what are they telling you are are they
telling you that they believe they will
only be gone a short time or do they
fear that this could last a very long
time and that they could be away from
home
for
much longer than they had anticipated
well most of my friends and colleagues
who have to leave their homes because
from
some of them did want to stay
so they went to the to to places inside
ukraine to the west of ukraine to the
central ukraine that is still
not uh safe there because
russia shells also that areas as well
but still it is of course safer than for
example in kharkiv now or in kiev and
what they want is they want to come back
as soon as possible to their homes to be
to return to their normal lives because
we are a big nation of 40 million people
we don't want you know to run we want to
fight and we want to
have control over ukrainian territory uh
which is uh according to the
international laws so uh i have myself
been offered many times by my friends a
place where i could stay in poland in
germany in macedonia in in moldova in
other countries because now everyone
here is
giving hand to ukraine and european
nations are united in in this so uh i
was offered that help and i'm really
thankful to to all of
those who
who help ukraine now but i as i have
said i do not want to leave
because i don't have any reasons for
that it's russian soldiers who have to
leave our territory and speaking of
those few who have
actually left and went to
poland for example or moldova
they usually make this because
they are really afraid and they have
small children and they are threatened
that if they will stay in ukraine even
in western ukraine where there are also
air strikes now that the children
can be harmed and
so they're protecting their small ones
olay obviously there is great concern
for the people of ukraine for those who
are staying for those who have decided
to leave but i want to ask you about
another aspect of this is there concern
on the part of you and your colleagues
for the safety of the humanitarian
workers that are responding to all of
this
yeah of course there is i mean we now
have you know uh our teams from the
norwegian refugee council they're in
kiev they're in
sierras which is a city that is fairly
close to what used to be the front lines
between government and
non-government-controlled areas and they
are hunkering down in in bomb shelters
uh as everybody else um and and as we
talked about i think it is incredibly
important that that they are able to
then when things stabilize a little bit
uh work uh work freely but i think you
know the most important part now for me
is really to keep a focus on the
civilians who are caught in this this
sort of unnecessary war and in areas of
active fighting we saw back from 2014
and 2015
that both sides ended up using weapons
that were
extremely dangerous to civilians area
weapons and we've seen confirmation of
such use of weapons again now
so i'm really worried that we will see
both displacement but we'll also see
much more damage to infrastructure to
houses
killings and injuries of civilians
and this is really what our focus should
be on now to try to stop that there
should be maximum diplomatic pressure to
stop that to not use such weapons and
then we need to scale up the
humanitarian assistance
so that we can address the needs that
are are going to be absolutely
staggering
it is a terrifying situation um very
concerning for so many of the people
inside of ukraine right now
we have run out of time so we're going
to have to leave the discussion there
thank you so much to all of our guests
maria avdiva jung gadini williams and
ole solvang
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story from me
muhammad jim jim the whole team here bye
for now
[Music]
you